et donc on a le plaisir de vous recevoir
pour cette audition monsieur
Jean-Paul Deron premier vice-président
de la Fédération de la pêche au niveau
national et Monsieur
Hamid Oumoussa directeur général donc de
la Fédération aussi Nationale de la
Pêche en France donc merci à vous de
d'avoir pris un peu de votre temps pour
qu'on puisse vous auditionner sur cette
mission
concernant la gestion durable de l'eau
une mission une question importante de
l'eau puisqu'on depuis quelques années
déjà et notamment 2022 une grande
sécheresse une année 2023 qui
démarre mal également
et donc cette audition donc je vous
rappelle fait l'objet d'un compte-rendu
public qui sera publié sur le site du
Sénat et ça permettra d'éclairer donc
les membres de la mission d'information
sur l'eau qui était lancée par le Sénat
début février à la demande du groupe
socialiste et nous avons comme
rapporteur mon ami Hervé Gillet c'est
l'acteur de Gironde
comme rapporteur et donc cette mission
que je préside comprend des sénateurs
représentants des tous les groupes
politiques c'est une mission
transpartisane comme on le fait
régulièrement au Sénat
et donc il s'agit de vous entendre pour
nous donner votre avis sur la politique
de l'eau
au niveau national et
nous avons pour objectif de déposer
notre rapport au mois de juillet début
juillet on espère après avoir fait
beaucoup d'auditions des visites sur le
terrain également
et on attend bien sûr de votre part un
éclairage sur les évolutions des
écosystèmes aquatiques
d'autre part les pistes de réflexion
pendant notamment à restaurer la
biodiversité
et également vos analyses sur les
objectifs de la politique de l'eau
est-ce qu'ils sont adaptés
les instruments juridiques est-ce que
les lois sur l'eau existantes doivent
être revues on a celle de 64 de 92 de
2006 bon elles sont là est-ce que un
moment donné il faudra les faire évoluer
et puis quels sont les changements
apportés pour mieux gérer l'eau sur
notre territoire donc voilà en gros les
les questions qui vont vous être posées
par notre rapporteur Hervé gilet à qui
je laisse la parole
bien merci monsieur le Président merci
cher ami je salue également mes
collègues qui sont présents pour cette
audition le président l'a rappelé on est
dans un contexte en plus particulier
conjoncturel
avec une sécheresse hivernale qui est
particulièrement importante donc qui
fait résonner le sujet parce que
malheureusement si nous n'avons pas de
pluviométrie importante dans les mois
qui viennent tous les usages tous les
usages vont souffrir
dans les mois à venir et on a déjà connu
des premiers arrêtés de sécheresse
au mois de janvier ce qui est quand même
incroyable
au niveau de cette situation je vous
propose de rentrer tout de suite dans le
vif du sujet vous êtes transmis bien sûr
les questions mais aimez-vous vous
lancer pour que vous puissiez nous
apporter des précisions sur d'abord
l'organisme bien sûr que vous
représentez qui est reconnu donc
d'utilité publique et sur
différentes missions que vous pouvez
exercer sur la surveillance la
protection des milieux la connaissance
du patrimoine qui est un sujet important
l'éducation la sensibilisation si à
l'environnement et puis les évolutions
des écosystèmes aquatiques vous êtes des
observateurs particulièrement attentifs
bien sûr des milieux quels sont les
observations majeures qu'on pouvait nous
faire effectivement remonter vous
inquiétudes comment le changement
climatique affecte ces écosystèmes là
également vous êtes aussi en ligne
directe pourrait-on dire de ces
évolutions et la conséquence donc
notamment au niveau des des débits et
puis du réchauffement des cours d'eau
qui est aussi un sujet particulièrement
important et moi qui suis un pêcheur de
la pêche à la truite mais on s'aperçoit
que la truite sauvage si malheureusement
la température est trop élevée il y a
pas de reproduction c'est bien clair
donc c'est voilà simplement un petit
exemple comme ça au passage
fario comment les activités humaines
affectent-elles les écosystèmes
aquatiques quels sont les effets des
pollutions aquatiques aujourd'hui qui
est un sujet qui monte bien évidemment
puissance partir au moment le spectre
qu'on observe de plus en plus important
mais le sujet des micropollants
plastiques devient de plus en plus
prégnant
je m'arrêtais là je relancerai après sur
les questions si vous voulez bien donc
Monsieur le Directeur Général monsieur
le Premier vice-président et j'ai cru
comprendre que vous avez que vous
exercez des responsabilités
polyvalentes sur le domaine de l'eau ce
qu'il faudra que votre parole n'en
prendra plus que de profondeur je vous
en prie
allez je commence merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteurs et
messieurs
merci pour
pour la pertinence du sujet vous savez
que demain le ministre
monsieur bichu annonce fera des annonces
importantes après un processus de
concertation assez large que l'on a bien
entendu contribué via le Comité national
de l'eau
vous avez également rappelé avec
justesse l'actualité qui est la note
depuis environ
un an de sécheresse
permanente continue avec des effets
connus on y reviendra dans un instant
bref vous dire combien nous sommes ravis
que le Sénat c'est pas la première fois
bien entendu que le Sénas
voilà travail sur un sujet
qui un autre sens
mobilise trop souvent de manière
ponctuelle vraisemblablement le décideur
public dans son acception la plus
générale qui s'ouvre
nous avons le bonheur à la Fédération
Nationale d'être né en tant que
structure en 2006 avec la loi sur l'eau
et les milieux aquatiques vous voyez on
a une
on a une naissance somme toute assez
singulière c'est la volonté conjuguée du
Parlement du gouvernement du ministre de
l'Écologie de l'époque et surtout des
pêcheurs de créer une grande
organisation nationale qui au niveau
parisien allait coordonner toutes les
fédérations départementales de pêche et
protection du milieu aquatique avec une
adhésion obligatoire de chacune d'entre
elles
94 fédérations départementales de dont
deux pardon
ultramarine une à la Réunion et une à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
un petit peu moins de 4000 associations
locales
quarantaine de milliers de bénévoles
un million 500 000 adhérents ce qui fait
de nous un des mouvements associatifs
les plus les plus vastes et les plus
denses
nous sommes la deuxième réseau
associatif français après le football
une expertise je pense plutôt bien
sereine sur ces questions de pêche et de
poissons ce sont d'ailleurs les deux
missions que le gouvernement que le
législateur pardon nous a confié par la
loi sur l'eau
une économie globalement estimée au gré
d'une étude réalisée avec un cabinet qui
s'appelle bip une étude de donc de 2012
qui a évalué notre impact global à 2
milliards 500 000 euros
un impact pour les territoires plutôt
forts plutôt marqué et un impact qui
n'est pas délocalisable
je tiens à préciser
voilà ce qu'on peut dire de manière
générale sur la Fédération Nationale de
la Pêche ensuite pour répondre à vos
questions très précisément à vos trois
questions sur les missions de la pêche
en matière disons de protection des
écosystèmes de connaissances etc je vous
dirai qu'on agit de deux manières
on agit au travers d'un levier important
qui s'appelle le levier financier et au
travers de d'un certain nombre de
leviers techniques sur le premier point
sur le levier financier
nous avons monté un réseau associatif
tout à fait singulier le pêcheur adhère
à une association il paye une cotisation
on adhérent à cette association il paye
également une cotisation à sa fédération
départementale de pêche et on adhérent
toujours à cette association il repeigne
une troisième fois une cotisation de
manière tout à fait indirecte pour
alimenter la Fédération Nationale de la
Pêche
cela veut dire que le pêcheur s'acquit
de trois séries de cotisations qui
viennent
qui viennent alimenter le fonctionnement
du réseau associatif ça c'est pour
l'argent associatif surtout le pêcheur
un peu avant tout le monde nous sommes
d'ailleurs la seule activité de loisirs
nautique à avoir monté ce système que
nous avons nous-mêmes proposé au moment
de la loi sur l'eau puisque le pêcheur
paye également une redevance aux agences
de l'eau qui s'appelle la redevance pour
les milieux aquatiques dont le montant
était estimé à grosso modo 8 millions
d'euros
c'est cette cotisation que j'évoquais
président qui nous permet au niveau
national de mettre en place à fond de
péricquoision et de soutien de nos
fédérations départementales bref de tout
le réseau infra-national
grâce à ce fond nous avons depuis 2006
créé au consolider 300 emplois
de haute technicité donc des techniciens
de l'environnement des ingénieurs des
emplois très qualifiés dans le domaine
de l'écologie aquatique ou bien dans le
domaine de ce que l'on appelle la
surveillance et l'éducation à
l'environnement se sont les fameuses
agents de développement que vous devez
certainement connaître puisque on est
quelques structures à employer cette
terminologie au financer à 100%
co-financer c'est du co-financement bien
entendu nous nous mettons à leur
disposition
un certain une grosse enveloppe ça
représente je vous ai dit quelques
chiffres juste après ça représente une
part importante mais ce n'est pas bien
entendu un financement intégral les
fédérations départementales disposent
également de leurs ressources propres
qui leur permettent de financer ses
postes
grâce à cette cotisation pardon à cette
cotisation nationale nous dégageons
ainsi entre 22 et 23 millions d'euros
suivant bien entendu le nombre de
pêcheurs et la très grande majorité de
ces 23 millions d'euros grosso modo 18
19 millions suivant les années sont
justement affectés à ces missions
d'intérêt général de soutien des emplois
en Fédération départementale mais
également à hauteur d'environ 5 millions
d'euros affectés à des travaux de
restauration de la continuité écologique
des travaux de connaissances des travaux
de renaturation et des travaux de
connaissances de toute la biodiversité
donc vous voyez on met à peu près 20
millions d'euros que l'on redistribue
très très directement aux fédérations
départementales pour exercer les
différentes missions qui sont les nôtres
au gré d'une convention avec le ministre
de l'éducation nationale que nous
signons depuis des heures des années des
années nous intervenons activement en
matière d'éducation
auprès des scolaires bien entendu mais
pas que nos intervenons également en
termes de sensibilisation auprès des
noms scolaires et nous faisons ainsi
passer une petite centaine de milliers
de personnes dans le cadre de nos ce
qu'on appelle des ateliers Pêche Nature
pour ceux qui connaissent notre monde
dans la Pessah il y a quelques années
des écoles de pêche mais la dénomination
école de pêche bon poser quelques
petites difficultés c'est une notion que
l'on réserve à l'éducation nationale
voilà pour
le financement direct pour les actions
indirectes vous savez certainement que
nous siègeons dans tout un tas
d'instances qui participent de
l'écologie comité nationale de l'eau
comité nationale de la transition
écologique comité nationale de la
biodiversité et bien entendu nous sommes
au conseil d'administration de l'OVB
d'ailleurs vous vos deux serviteurs en
l'occurrence c'est assez recettes
occasion que bien entendu en militent
pour que la loi sur l'eau de 2006 dans
son esprit et dans son contenu soit
toujours respecté en faisant remonter
notre expertise notre savoir-faire pour
alimenter les différents débats pour
alimenter les différentes propositions
de décret ou de textes réglementaires
nous organisons également une fois par
an
des grandes journées techniques au cours
desquelles en réunit entre 200 et 250
ingénieurs pour partager sur toutes les
thématiques qui peuvent être les leurs
au quotidien en matière de connaissance
en matière de restauration de continuité
comme je le disais tout à l'heure bref
tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer en
termes de travaux en lien avec les
écosystèmes
aquatiques enfin je mettrai en
perspective un dernier point
qui est du ressort plutôt communication
depuis trois ans maintenant nous lançons
à date fixe une grande stratégie de
communication pour sensibiliser sur la
rivière le thème 1 c'était il y a deux
ans c'était sur la question de la
gestion quantitative
tellement ne peut plus d'actualité
aujourd'hui encore l'année dernière
c'était sur les poissons migrateurs avec
tout un tas de retombées notamment
médiatiques nous avons également réalisé
un très beau film de sensibilisation à
cette espèce à ces espèces qui sont
vraiment très grande difficulté et cette
année nous pensons
anglais cette grande campagne de
communication nationale sur la notion de
connaissance des écosystèmes de
connaissances de la rivière pour mieux
sensibiliser notamment les décideurs
publics voilà je pense pour le propos
introductif pour la présentation de la
maison si naturellement il y avait des
questions ensuite tout à fait prêt à
répondre mais voilà je crois que je
réponds et à la présentation de la
maison et d'autre part aux différentes
actions que l'on mène de manière directe
ou indirecte sur les trois leviers que
vous aviez énoncé président
de la fédération nationale avec ses
principes fondament enfin essentiels
alors moi je voudrais effectivement
puisque par rapport à cette question
vous avez dit donc qu'on a pu observer
ces dernières années moi je voudrais
resituer ça et j'y reviendrai dans un
second temps à une échelle de temps je
dirais de 30 ans en arrière pourquoi je
dis ça c'est parce que vous le savez
peut-être pas mais ça fait plus de 30
ans qu'en tant que élu bénévole
demandait partement je officie à la
destinée ce département sur la
protection de l'eau et des milieux
aquatiques et des poissons migrateurs
mais aussi sur le fait que je dirais
donc
quand je suis arrivé en fonction
j'ai eu à souffrir les affres je peux
dire les affres je dirais des derniers
travaux d'hydroïque agricole connexes
je pourrais vous sortir des photos mais
ça aucun intérêt mais si ce n'est que de
montrer quand même que j'irai c'est ça a
été une longue évolution un peu
sournoise et qui sait qui s'est prolongé
et qui continue à se plonger puisque je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la question est on
y viendra peut-être tout à l'heure dans
les propositions en ce qui nous concerne
l'usage l'aménagement des territoires
elle est essentielle au cœur du sujet
indépendamment bien évidemment de
l'aspect conjoncturel de la sécheresse
qui devient structurel et d'impact du
dérèglement climatique mais je voulais
intervenir là-dessus parce que on ne
tiendra c'est vraiment un point central
c'est à dire qu'en fait on hérite
malheureusement d'une situation qui a
été engagée et puis au fur et à mesure
ça s'est dégradé à tel point c'est que
j'ai vu derrière aussi disparaître des
cours d'eau on continue de voir des
cigarettes des zones humides or les
outils de planification sur l'eau étant
depuis plus de 20 ans dans les instances
de bassin au comité de bassin de
Bretagne vous comprenez que ces éléments
nous interpellent ça fait partie
peut-être du porno du sujet je sais pas
si vous avez pu le remarquer mais nous
travaillons pour voir comment on peut
conforter l'inscription de la ressource
de l'eau dans les documents d'urbanisme
que ça soit au niveau des scottes ou des
pluies des PLU de telle manière à mieux
gérer ce qu'on appelle le stock le fil
de l'eau partant du principe que si on
accueille des populations il faut aussi
créer les conditions pour que la
ressource soit à la fois là préservée et
donc en tout cas c'est une orientation
sur laquelle nous travaillons
merci de ces précisions sachez que quand
professionnellement je suis arrivé dans
une collectivité territoriale
établissement puis de coopération terre
communale donc je connais les deux
facettes du sujet notamment sur la
question des questions d'urbanisme
d'aménagement du territoire et quand je
parle d'aménagement du territoire c'est
l'usage du sol c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui le vrai état d'enjeu
c'est comment maintenir l'eau au plus
près de là où elle est mais on est
d'accord parce que là gestion du fil de
l'eau et la gestion du pluvial
aujourd'hui plutôt que tout mettre dans
un réseau séparatif peut-être qu'il y a
des solutions plus intelligentes pour
partie en différenciant au niveau des
territoires on est bien d'accord donc en
fait bon
quand je reviens j'en fais le focus un
petit peu en arrière pour me projeter
dans le dans le moment présent
on a effectivement vu une autre décrue
sur mon vieux au niveau de ma part de la
dégradation physique et de communiquer
tout ce qui est ce que sont les
écosystèmes aquatiques notamment sur
l'hydromorphologie l'hydromorphologie
était un élément essentiel dans la
gestion de la ressource dans la comment
dire dans la gestion effectivement
j'irai mais que ce soit sur l'aspect
qualitatif que quantitatif parce que on
parle de sécheresse mais on peut pas
aussi d'inondation et les deux les deux
vont de pair de toute façon au même
raison les mêmes désordres et pas
forcément les mieux conséquences donc
toujours est-il que effectivement donc
cette dégradation lente Sourn ça a
continué à s'opérer dans les territoires
et continue de s'opérer je vous cite un
exemple récemment encore le préfet de
mon département annonçait la déclaration
du Conseil public d'une mise à deux fois
de voix d'une infrastructure linéaire de
transport que je ne citerai pas bien
évidemment mais avec une destruction de
40 hectares de zones humides ça
interpelle en pleine période de
sécheresse et en pleine période où il
faut maintenir gérer les infrastructures
naturelles les préserver et on n'arrête
pas de dire qu'il faut préserver les
zones humides la question qu'on peut se
poser derrière c'est d'abord le respect
de la séquence évitez réduire compensées
et ne pas tomber directement la
compensation et quand en plus on va
chercher des compensations sur un autre
bassinversement je rappelle que la
gestion de l'eau est le pays a logique
implacable géologique géographique qui
est le bassin de bassin versant juste
sur cette question qui est intéressante
des compensations là vous posez la
question de l'intérêt d'une compensation
qui est situé sur un autre bassin
versant par rapport à au bassin qui est
réellement impacté donc c'est vrai que
le sujet peut-être mis sur la table il y
a aussi aujourd'hui un sujet qui monte
un peu en puissance sur la qualité des
compensations comment véritablement les
évaluer sachant que ces dernières ne
sont pas toujours évaluées aussi dans le
temps c'est à dire que les ce qu'on met
sur la table n'est pas forcément ce
qu'on retrouve sur le terrain notamment
dans ces évolutions est-ce que c'est des
sujets que vous partagez ou pas alors je
partage totalement parce que là
effectivement j'ai eu l'occasion là
aussi de d'être content en procès de
contentieux Satan de dossier de pas de
part de nos fonctions nos missions forcé
de constater que la vraie question de
fond qui se pose déjà avant de tomber
dans la compensation c'est quelles sont
les vrais véritables mesures j'avais pas
encore un projet donné on a mis en place
on a géré comment
identifier pour favoriser l'évitement et
après réduire et en
ultime lieu la compensation alors la
compensation vous l'avez vous l'avez dit
elle se pose à travers le spectre de la
pertinence de la compensation ou
décompensation qui sont proposées de
leur localisation et puis bénéficiaires
bien évidemment la question de suivi et
d'évaluation sauf qu'en général et on le
voit sur d'autres dossiers on ira
l'occasion d'y revenir parce que j'ai vu
qu'on avait dans les questions on avait
les questions sur la production
d'énergie à partir de l'eau et là on
aura largement le largement de quoi
alimenter le son mauvais jeu le nom de
la part le débat mais en tous les cas
effectivement cette notion était elle
est essentielle enfin ce qui me concerne
maintenant pour ce qui est du gérer de
la phase dans laquelle qu'une traversons
actuellement pour revenir virer plutôt
dans le temps présent aujourd'hui le
dérèglement climatique ce n'est pas un
changement climatique c'est vraiment
véritablement un dérèglement on
l'observe depuis 5 ans avec comme le
problème d'un effet cumulatif cumulatif
sur l'hydrologie cumulative sur les
élévations des températures et
malheureusement puisque nous le
constatons et nos collègues le font sur
le terrain puisque on a mis en place
gérer un réseau de suivi suivant les
départements de la
[Musique]
quotidien voit les choses j'aurais pu
prendre des des photos et vous faire
voir de ce que j'ai encore pu constaté
sur l'autoroute tout à l'heure en venant
prendre mon train ou moi je suis quand
même assez attiré je dois le dire
atterré qu'on puisse continuer j'irai
sans se poser les vraies questions de
l'impact de l'usage du sol de la
ménagement et ça vaut pour tous les
compartiments économiques c'est pas je
ne cible pas une activité en particulier
même si quand j'évoquais les travaux
d'hydriques agricoles collègues sur
rendement nous l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
de dans les territoires c'est de faire
que on maintienne le réseau
hydrographique et notamment les têtes de
bassin versant parce qu'elles sont
essentielles à la gestion de la
ressource sur les aspects qualitatifs et
quantitatifs c'est que ce chevelu nous
on a l'habitude de l'appeler le chevelu
alors vous avez compris que j'étais mal
placé pour en parler parce qu'il reste
derrière mon catogan mais ça c'était
pour la note d'humour
non non c'est malheureusement un signe
autre qu'il y ait à mon âge qui avance à
chacun et qui fait que peut-être que les
soucis se sont accumulés aussi et les
préoccupations environnementales avec
mais bon c'était une petite parenthèse
une petite digression de la part non pas
toujours est-il que je pense qu'il faut
vraiment intégrer ça je pense qu'il a la
question aujourd'hui elle est
essentielle c'est comment on arrête je
dirais de
déménager les territoires de protéger
les têtes de bassin versant et de
collectivement je dirais engagé les
actions que ça emporte les contraintes
alors c'est vrai que ça va ça nécessite
aussi une vraie réflexion et là c'est un
acteur du comité de bassin qui parle la
nécessité qu'il va falloir vraiment
véritablement qu'il solidarité à mon
aval si la capacité des territoires en
tête de bassin versant à se développer
quel que soit l'usage économique ne va
pas être le même malheureusement et très
contraint plus compte plus contraint que
dans les parties avales parce que il y
aura plus de ressources en eau il y a
etc donc il y a une capacité à se
développer voilà mais je me permets de
sortir un petit peu de questionnaire
juste pour vérifier puisque au travers
de de vos différentes responsabilités
mais qui touchent directement votre
responsabilité au fil niveau de la
Fédération nationale de pêche du coup
sur l'organisation et la gouvernance
territoriale nous sommes plutôt sur des
logiques de confortation d'une
gouvernance à l'échelle du bassin bien
sûr mais dans une logique ensuite de
subsidiarité qui s'appuie sur des EPTB
des épages avec un fonctionnement
aujourd'hui au niveau des sages et des
clés qui semblent globalement
satisfaisant mais qui mériterait
peut-être quelques améliorations sur
lequel vous pouvez peut-être avoir des
remarques effectivement à faire dans ce
cadre-là ce qui correspond ce qui
respecterait cette vision du chevelu et
de la solidarité aussi à mon aval qui
est absolument essentiel aujourd'hui
donc peut-être que voilà vous avez un
niveau d'analyse et peut-être des
propositions sur le sujet
le propos général d'abord si vous voulez
bien
sur la gouvernance
telle qu'elle est structurée aujourd'hui
à savoir disons une approche par par
bassin autour de comité de bassin d'un
côté les agences de l'autre et ensuite
une gouvernance très très ouverte des
comités de bassin particulièrement
ouverts 150 de son personnel pour des
réunions sur l'eau bon voilà on estime
que c'est quand même les gouvernance
particulièrement ouverte elle n'est pas
exclusive d'ailleurs
on a fait un très grand boulot au Comité
national de l'eau pour savoir si tout le
monde était à peu près bien représenté
il est apparu que
oui oui
duquel était ressorti que globalement
c'était plutôt bien représentatif même
si sur un certain il y avait peut-être
quelques problèmes d'équilibre mais bon
là je vous laisse regarder dans dans le
rapport
oui oui oh ben vous savez c'est un très
très vieux dossier c'est un très très
vieux dossier après on a vu aussi émergé
au gritz ces débats tout un tas
d'organisations qui n'avaient de
représentative que pas grand chose je
pourrais vous donner quelques exemples
si il y avait besoin mais pas dans le
compte-rendu
parce que bon voilà il faut aussi
accepter cette idée que quand on vient à
la politique de l'eau voilà il y a
beaucoup de concertation il y a beaucoup
de discussions et on n'a pas raison
contre tout le monde mais on aura
l'occasion de parler de continuité
écologique tout à globalement vous vous
validez ce système de l'organisation
nous plaît plutôt bien
très objectivement si vous mettez l'État
dans la gouvernance
de la politique de l'eau nous notre
attente c'est que l'État soit
véritablement plus présent sur cette
question là parce que
ça revient d'ailleurs à vous répondre
sur la question numéro 9 je crois sur
nos propositions
[Musique]
nous pensons véritablement que
l'enjeu est crucial
de la politique de Loïc crucial il est à
ce point crucial que pour paraphraser
les propos je crois d'un ancien
président de comité de bassin d'un
actuel président du comité de bassin
Michael époque a été rapportée de la loi
sur l'eau ça mériterait presque un
ministère dédié à cette politique de
voilà ça nous sommes intimement
convaincus après avoir vécu tout un tas
d'organisations qui ont bougé suivant
les couleurs politiques du gouvernement
on commence à se convaincre que cette
question est à ce point crucial qu'elle
doit revenir son contrat et la seule
manière de d'en faire une politique
sectorielle centrale c'est d'en faire un
ministère dédié
ça c'est pour les la proposition j'en
profite si vous voulez bien se rapporter
monsieur le Président
a parlé des grands changements
l'un de nos meilleurs thermomètres
c'est la quantité d'eau dans les
rivières celui-là on peut vous l'assurer
et pour nous il n'y a pas de débat
juste quand vous dites on peut vous
l'assurer on voit que il faut pour nous
conforter encore le niveau de mesure de
qualité
d'évaluation des ressources à l'échelle
du comité de bassin sur un certain
nombre de sujets on voit qu'au niveau
des nappes et des nappes profondes on
connaît pas encore tout le réservoir et
le stockage est-ce qu'au niveau des
débits quantités etc là vous avez toutes
les mesures alors j'ai tiré
je dirais que cette question ne souffre
pas à ma connaissance de discussion sur
les débits tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que
ils ont baissé et que la trajectoire est
à -10 jusqu'à -40 étant précisé que ces
chiffres sont en cours de révision
ça je pense que vous avez eu pas mal
d'éléments sur ce point-là ça veut dire
que sur ce point très précis président
on a une proposition à vous faire
ce qu'il faut une loi sur l'eau on y
reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure
on pense à ce stade que la question
mérite d'être posée en tout cas j'irai
même que pour nous il faudra
vraisemblablement une nouvelle loi sur
l'eau et l'un des points clés à discuter
c'est ce fameux débit réservé qui était
aujourd'hui fixé au 1/10 du module avec
tout un tas d'exception voilà
je fais bien entendu le lien entre ce
débit réservé pour la nature pour les
écosystèmes pour les la nature qui est
une éponge
celui-là c'est un c'est un débit légal
qui est fixé dans le
pardon excusez-moi ça c'est l'ancienne
appellation c'est 214 17 du code de
l'environnement c'est le débit que doit
laisser tout usager de l'eau
d'en arriver ça veut dire qu'il peut
prendre tout ou partie de la rivière si
je puis dire mais il ne peut pas toucher
ce qu'on appelle le débit réservé voilà
pour faire court
Ier de maintenir
une qualité
les attaques sur le bureau
il y en a j'ai l'impression celui dont
je vous parle en tout cas il est
législatif il est réglementaire il est
fixé dans les actes d'autorisation c'est
pas tellement un débit qui se discute si
je puis dire sauf si vous êtes
véritablement dans les exceptions
à mon avis c'est très variable mais
enfin c'est quand même là on est le
seuil bas si vous voulez le débit
réserve le débit réservé c'est le seuil
bas donc ça peut pas être en dessous du
déo c'est pas possible ça c'est vraiment
le seuil bas c'est
c'est pour éviter que la nature
ne soit mise à mal par des prélèvements
qui ne seraient pas
[Musique]
monsieur le Président oui je voudrais
qu'on raconte non pas compléter sur le
plan technique parce que effectivement
qu'on l'a dit comment directeur général
je pense qu'il faut la notion de débit
réservé elle est fixée par le code de
l'environnement et ça paraît être
essentiel je vais vous y distraire un
propos très très récent puisque j'étais
un comité ressources en eau hier dans
mon département et la question donc vous
savez des quatre seuils qui amènent à
mettre la comment dire à gérer la
ressource en eau dans les départements
c'est de vigilance d'alerte à l'air trop
forcé et de crise on s'aperçoit dans et
c'est surtout là où est l'enjeu et c'est
ça exactement le même propos sur le
débit objective DTH c'est tout dépend où
on place la station de jaugeage où on
met le où on met le comment dire le
thermomètre si je pouvais exprimer ainsi
dans le bassin versant et vous comprenez
bien que avant que on a on déclenche
l'alerte quelquefois les cours d'eau en
tête de bassin sont déjà assez
grosse tension mais moi je voulais
revenir sur les aspects gouvernance ça
me paraît important parce que c'est un
sujet pour moi ça me paraît comme j'irai
donc pour ne pas dire essentiel je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'organisation
territoriale qui s'appuie sur les grands
bassins hydrographiques à l'échelon des
outils planifié que sont les schémas
directeur d'un aménagement gestion des
comment dire des eaux ont suivi une
évolution depuis la loi de 92 entre
autres et puis donc on vue évoluer la
composition même des comités de bassin
donc je suis bien passé pour le savoir
parce que ça fait plus de 20 ans que je
suis dans dedans et j'ai vu comment ça
avait évolué et comment il y avait eu un
rééquilibrage qu'on le veuille ou non
j'irai des représentatives des
représentations après la vraie question
qu'on peut se poser c'est effectivement
l'équilibre entre les commandes les
collèges mais ça c'est ça c'est un autre
sujet par contre ce sur quoi je me
permets d'insister aussi c'est de
décliner ensuite puisque vous avez parlé
des épingles vous avez parlé des EPTB et
vous avez parlé des sages enfin des
commissions locales de l'eau
les commissions locales de l'eau elle
comment elle est sage sont issus de la
loi 92 malheureusement on peut dire
enfin on leur Bretagne on a la chance
d'être un bassin très bien couvert en
matière de commission locale de l'eau de
schéma d'aménagement de gestion des eaux
ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas à
l'échange du territoire national parce
qu'on voit qu'elle est trop un peu trop
dans la raquette or j'insiste enfin moi
je et avec comment c'est ce que je
disais lors du dernier comité national
du 5 janvier dernier à la ministre qui
s'est interrogé et qui nous interrogeait
en disant mais je ne comprends pas que
les commissions locales de l'eau
n'arrive pas à passer à l'action
je peux dire qu'ils sont dans l'action
au quotidien et qui plus est le gros
avantage c'est que là on est au plus
près du territoire avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes autour de la table et
avec une représentation à peu près
équilibrée et qui fait que on arrive à
co-construire une politique territoriale
de l'eau à travers le schéma
d'aménagement gestion des eaux
là où j'ai fait un petit non pas
digression même un petit coup d'un petit
coup de ligne un petit coup de griffe
parce que j'ai pas pour habitude pour
ceux qui me connaissent de ménager mais
mes propos et de pratiquer la langue de
bois
ce que j'ai répondu à la ministre c'est
ce qui est quand même dommageable c'est
quand le premier représentant d'État
donc le préfet dans un département
saisit la commission locale de l'eau
pour me dire demander la modification
d'un règlement du sage enfin du schéma
d'aménagement pour permettre à
destruction des zones humides et
implanter des méthaniseurs ça pose ça
pose un problème sur la question et sur
le rôle que peut avoir l'État en matière
de cohérence parce qu'il y a pour moi il
y a il y a le gouvernement il y a une
ligne politique qui est tracée et elle
doit être à même dans tous les
territoires pourquoi c'est celle-ci se
déclinerait différemment suivant les
territoires alors certes il faut les
adapter suivant les contraintes etc mais
globalement la ligne de conduite est la
stratégie elle est fixée la faille de
route en théorie elle est fixée et ça
c'est un vrai sujet c'est un vrai sujet
parce que aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je
veux insister là dessus on a
véritablement besoin me semble-t-il
président du comité bastions à Bretagne
il dirait la même chose que moi vraiment
besoin de gérer renforcer le rôle des
commissions locales de l'eau je pense
que ça c'est important parce qu'elles
sont plus près des territoires et en
prise directe en prise directe avec les
sujets de leur bassin versant puisque je
reviens à cette à cette logique
implacable qui est la notion de bassin
versant au plus près des territoires au
plus près des préoccupations et au plus
près des contraintes du territoire parce
que aujourd'hui si on fixe le cadre à
l'échelle du bassin les deux sont c'est
aussi ça le début objectif des tirages
c'est à des points d'eau dans le stage
mais c'est simplement entre guillemets
un indicateur comme un autre nous ce qui
nous apparaît aujourd'hui moi ce qui est
c'est la notion de débit réservé et de
débit minimum biologique pourquoi je dis
ça c'est parce que hier par exemple on
s'aperçoit que dans le comité dans les
seuils qui ont été fixés d'un certain
nombre d'arrêter préfectoraux j'irai qui
devait mettre en place encadrer comment
l'encadrement donc des prélèvements et
la gestion de la ressourcement dans les
territoires on s'aperçoit du Seuil dans
certains cas sont en dessous des débits
minimum biologiques et en deçà
il s'applique sur tous les cours d'eau
qui bénéficient d'un soutien des tirages
alors que le débit réservé lui c'est pas
le cas il s'applique sur l'ensemble des
cours d'eau et c'est pour maintenir
effectivement abandonné suffisamment
d'eau pour
connaissance
si vous voulez
si vous permettez parce que leur tourne
si on a des collègues c'est notre triste
sénateurs qui veulent poser des
questions on va faire une petite série
de questions et rigole ou
madame latrix
madame blatrix
oui merci monsieur le Président merci à
vous pour ces éléments va peut-être
avancer sur sur les questions qui vous
ont été posées
sur les les effets des nouvelles
pollutions aquatiques qu'elle en est
votre analyse et un autre sujet
évidemment qui a fait l'objet de
nombreux débats au Sénat les impacts de
la production hydroélectriques c'est
vrai que on a d'un côté les syndicats de
rivière qui prônent de plus en plus en
arrasement des seuils pour retrouver une
véritable continuité et d'un autre côté
vous avez les propriétaires de Moulins
qui évoquent le fait que l'angoula
permet de créer une réserve d'eau donc
voilà je voudrais avoir votre analyse de
l'électricité mais sur la petite
et avoir votre votre analyse là dessus
Eric
je reprends président
à peu près
disparition des poissons d'eau douce
c'était principalement dû à la pollution
c'est pas forcément à cause du
changement climatique aujourd'hui en
plus des pollutions dont certaines se
sont quand même estompées parce que
l'eau est quand même traitée par les
stations d'épuration on voit que le
manque d'eau
et la hausse des températures des
rivières
impact considérablement la biodiversité
au sens large alors pour
j'aimerais savoir votre
votre vision notamment sur les vaisseaux
espèces invasifs parce qu'on se rend
compte que il y a un changement complet
dans
les types de poissons qu'on peut
retrouver dans les dans les rivières on
retrouve maintenant des aspects
invasives quasiment en nombre supérieur
que les espaces qui sont là depuis
longtemps
donc votre vision là-dessus et puis pour
reprendre aussi ce que dit ma collègue
sur la suppression des seuils moi
j'aimerais vous entendre sur
cette suppression des seuils où on a
finalement à peu près la même règle que
les seuils fassent 30 cm de haut qu'ils
en fassent 4 mètres de haut j'aimerais
savoir en termes de continuité
écologique si on a exactement la même
problématique quand on supprime un seuil
qui fait 30 cm quand on a supprimé qui
fait 4 mètres
c'est essentiel que l'on aborde cette
question de la continuité écologique
parce que très honnêtement
malgré nos meilleures efforts les uns et
les autres
[Musique]
depuis la léma je crois que avec le
Sénat nous avons un peu de difficulté
donc c'est essentiel qu'on en dise un
mot et pourtant on en a fait des
auditions je peux vous l'assurer au
préalable si vous me permettez d'un mot
revenir sur votre question sur la
gouvernance on a pas dit un mot sur les
ptgge je voulais vous dire
en particulier
il y avait merci monsieur le Président
de me donner la parole dans vos propos
un truc dans l'introductif j'ai
j'ai entendu deux choses le premier
c'est la création d'un ministère de
l'Eau dédié qui est une qui me paraît
qui me paraît plutôt pertinent mais sur
la fin des propos du président d'orange
j'entendais aussi le fait de pouvoir
renforcer
la gouvernance au niveau des clés donc
avant que vous puissiez répondre sur la
gouvernance aujourd'hui quel est le bon
niveau de gouvernance de votre point de
vue dans dans en matière d'eau dans si
on avait à se projeter dans les années
dans les dans les cinq à dix ans à venir
au point de vue quel est la bonne
gouvernance de l'eau en France
vos propositions en termes de lutte
contre les pollutions je crois qu'on a
eu cette plante nitrates par exemple et
est-ce que pour vous ça s'améliore et
est-ce que vous avez des propositions
sur ces sujets
la dimension
allez-y
alors je
reviens donc à cette question de la
gouvernance pour vous dire Président
Monsieur rapporteur combien nous sommes
convaincus que l'outil ptge
est un bon outil dès lors qu'il est mis
en place de bonne foi
que la gouvernance est respectée que les
objectifs sont respectés que le cahier
des charges qui a été élaboré par les
uns et les autres signés par les uns et
les autres et correctement
mis en oeuvre et que l'État joue bien la
place qui doit être lassée ça juste je
pense que globalement tout le monde
partage un peu vos intentions on a juste
un petit un petit question c'est le fait
que pour faire court et je m'en excuse
déjà auprès des collègues on peut avoir
des accords et des consensus qui sont
trouvés à l'échelle du territoire qui
peuvent être remise en question au
niveau national ce qu'on a déjà vécu or
il faudrait que quand le consensus se
trouve au niveau des territoires
la vie ou l'accompagnement du National
se fasse au même niveau et qu'on n'est
pas non plus dans le temps en plus un
peu différé voilà qu'en pensez-vous
j'allais vous dire que c'est dans les
deux sens les remises en cause
on a vu des concertations je vous en
donne une comme ça je fais le lien avec
la continuité écologique on a vu
d'excellentes concertations se faire
pour rétablir ce que l'on appelle le bon
le le potentiel de développement de
l'hydroélectricité on a fait par bassin
5 années de travail par bassin versant
cinq années de travail nous fait des
l'État les collectivités les
propriétaires des moulins etc 5 années
de travail pour arriver à évaluer le
potentiel de développement
de manière contradictoire et bien malgré
cela
un certain nombre d'associations sont
venus voir le Sénat sans aller voir
l'Assemblée nationale et dire non
ce bilan ce potentiel n'est pas bon il
faut le remettre en cause on a des
études on a des chiffres qui sont
différents donc vous savez ça se fait
dans les deux sens c'est l'histoire de
jeux d'acteurs c'est vrai que c'est
épuisant
c'est le prix de la démocratie mais
j'entends
on a un certain nombre de cas à sur des
retenues également ou les acteurs ont
établi tout un tas de tout un tas de
protocoles d'ailleurs notre fédération
nos fédérations pardon s'inscrivent
quand elles estiment que c'est utile à
s'inscrivent dans ces protocoles locaux
notamment pour dire voilà il faudrait
une agriculture peut-être plus
agroécologique sur sur un certain nombre
de territoires quand on arrive à
négocier un débit réservé j'y reviens
vous voyez un débit réservé plus élevé
que ne le dit la réglementation nous
fédérations sont tout à fait aptes à
dire ok on y va alors après que le
gouvernement Vienne invalider corriger
oui je vois bien à quoi vous faites
référence mais j'ai pas une position
bien enfin bien frimer là-dessus c'est
un problème plus qui concerne le
fonctionnement du Sénat l'état etc
c'est pas que le fonctionnement du Sénat
enfin je voudrais pas être long parce
qu'il y a d'autres réponses à apporter
on pourrait dire un mot sur les sur la
continuité parce que c'est quand même le
point à mon avis sur lequel il faut
qu'on se dise un certain nombre de
choses puisque le dossier est très
ancien alors je voudrais revenir à une
chose bien simple
et en démarre toujours nos propos comme
ça sur la continuité et les moulins etc
on a une réglementation du la fin du 19e
siècle qui nous dit partout vous
installez un ouvrage vous devez mettre
une échelle à poissons voilà ce qu'elle
dit pour faire court c'est des anciens
19ème siècle c'est très vieux 1860 vous
avez cité tout à l'heure vous voyez
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez cité la
loi sur l'eau de 92 vous avez signalé
pardon la loi de 2006
mais pas signalé la loi de 84 sur la
pêche votez pourtant à l'unanimité à
l'Assemblée nationale votez à
l'unanimité à l'Assemblée nationale et
c'est elle
qui consolide qui consacre
législativement la notion de débit
réservé vitale pour le milieu naturel et
la notion de continuité écologique
vitale pour le peuplement piscicole ce
n'est que la loi sur l'eau de 2006 qui a
transféré ses articles vers la partie
haut du code de l'environnement je
voudrais je voulais vous le dire parce
que cette loi est fondamentale alors sur
la continuité donc une disposition de la
fin du 19e siècle tout un tout un tas de
jeux d'acteurs l'installation d'énormes
barrages
qui n'ont pas été dénoncés par nos
structures qui ont été accompagnées
puisque ces gros barrages faisaient
partie de l'indépendance énergétique
faisait partie de l'intérêt général de
la production d'hydroélectricité
d'activités économiques qu'on a pas eu
de difficultés avec ces gros barrages on
s'échamaillés sur un certain nombre
d'entre eux mais toujours toujours nous
avons su rester à la table de négocier
son de discussion pour établir le
fonctionnement des débits réservés le
fonctionnement des échelles à poissons
proposer des solutions de suivi on a
toujours travaillé en étroite
collaboration que ce soit avec EDF la
CNR etc
sur les petits ouvrages
là ce que nous constatons
c'est tout simplement que on a entre 100
et 150 000 ouvrages de toute nature qui
barre la continuité écologique
je voudrais casser ici un mythe
les poissons ne peuvent pas sauter des
maîtres et des mètres ça n'existe pas
alors ça existe à la télé dans des films
dans des dessins animés mais je voulais
vous le dire mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ça n'existe pas ça pour vous
emmener où vous voulez on les reçoit
ensemble on entourage ça ça n'existe pas
c'est des images d'Épinal mais ce n'est
pas possible donc toutes les
interventions que l'on entend nous
dans le cadre de commission le vote
Solonet etc etc et qui laisse imaginer
que le saumon peut sauter plusieurs
mètres ce n'est pas possible ça il faut
casser ça il faut vraiment que ça
s'arrête parce que on entend depuis très
longtemps je peux vous dire que c'est
une négation
de nos missions
de nos statuts et du travail au
quotidien de chacun d'entre nous voilà
une fois qu'on a dit ça sur les moulins
les rapporteurs au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée on fait un travail
remarquable en 2006 ils ont trouvé des
compromis satisfaisants pour tout le
monde très bon très très bon à l'époque
malheureusement on a lancé ce qu'on
appelle le pars le plan de restauration
de la continuité écologique en grande
pompe tout le monde l'a accompagné les
uns et les autres nous l'avons
accompagné tout se passait bien à partir
de 2012 ça a commencé à tourner dans
l'autre sens on ne sait pas trop
exactement pourquoi enfin on est là
quelques idées il y a une vérité à
remettre en cause de manière
substantielle la continuité écologique
pour
permettre au moulin d'exister personne
ne les remettant en question dès lors
qu'il respectait la loi bien entendu la
continuité écologique le débit raisin
etc mais sinon rien d'autre rien d'autre
et pour autant
depuis 26 a aujourd'hui le Sénat à
chacune des grandes de loi de l'écologie
il y a des amendements sur les moulins
sur la continuité écologique à tel point
que on a inventé
je ne parle que voilà
on les a tous suivis c'était passionnant
avec bon quelques erreurs comme je l'ai
relevé tout à l'heure
mais
nous pensons très humblement que le
Parlement est parti trop loin dans les
droits qu'il a accordé aux propriétaires
de Moulins en matière de continuité
écologique puisque
au gré d'une loi ils ont tout simplement
été considérés comme ne devons pas
respecter la continuité écologique vous
imaginez que un ouvrage d'AEP doit
respecter la continuité et un moulin non
voilà ce qui a voté le Parlement le
Conseil d'État très récemment a dit
ça ne paraît pas tout à fait
conventionnelle
ça me paraît pas tout à fait
conventionnelle arrive la loi ENR
énergies renouvelable on a là aussi vu
tout un tas de
sur les moulins
etc et finalement au gré de la CMP etc
le Parlement a décidé
d'effacer d'abroger l'article de 114
18:1 qui accordait des droits
substantiels et exorbitant au moulin et
je pense que là on revient à une
situation qui s'appelle un peu avec la
disparition de cette de cette OVNI
juridique j'allais dire puisque il était
qualifié d'inconventionnés par le
Conseil d'État
alors pour vous dire deux trois petites
choses quand même importantes sur la
continuité et les moulins
oui ça va être un point important
personne ne revendique la disparition
des moulins nous avons tous des enfants
nous avons tous une histoire nous avons
tous font particulièrement de notre
patrimoine ce qui est demandé
dans certains départements où il y avait
une volonté quand même de détruire un
certain nombre de seuils de Moulins faut
pas le l'ignorer non plus il y a eu des
excès de l'administration et de ses
excès son nez aussi c'est problème
président qui ont été
les agences de l'eau ont aidé si vous
voulez des propriétaires de Moulins à
détruire leur seuil on aurait pu
concevoir que la chance de l'eau aide
certains propriétaires de Moulins à
faire les travaux pour la continuité
écologique on aurait pu le voir dans
notre sens
un témoignage madame pour remettre un
peu comme on dit chez moi le clocher au
centre du village tu vas mettre là je
vais remettre le moulin au centre du
village vous voyez je suis très direct
oui mais mais nous aussi il se trouve
que je travaille une architecture donc
si je vois je suis pas convaincu de la
préservation du patrimoine qui serait
l'être par contre la préservation du
patrimoine n'importe pas effectivement
distortation distorsion pardon de
traitement entre citoyens notamment sur
la question de la gestion de la
ressources en nous la préservation de la
biodiversité et de l'environnement par
rapport au respect du droit et au
respect des obligations attachées
sur ce point sur ce point on a et quand
vous dites l'Agence de l'Eau moi je vous
dis je vous apporter un témoignage pour
avoir travaillé pendant ce que ça fait
des années des dizaines d'années qu'on y
travaille
je vais même pas vous évoquer les
différents classements les ouvrages
prioritaires parce qu'il y a des
ouvrages même priorité à côté des
définis et on n'a pas été fichu de les
mettre aux normes je pense que dans deux
siècles on y sera encore pour faire
simple pour faire simple et c'est un élu
de terrain qui vous parle madame c'est
pour vous dire que ça devient un peu ça
devient je pense un peu insupportable
quand on rentre dans la désinformation
mais pas vous pas mais sur le sur nos
territoires parce que on a essayé nous
les premiers à l'époque on associer les
propriétaires de Moulins dans les
commissions locales de l'eau pour les
faire participer la seule revendication
qu'ils ont eu c'est un c'est d'échapper
au droit au motif qui pourrait produire
d'électricité au motifs qui peuvent
avoir un magnifique plan d'eau devant
chez eux même s'il monte à 40 degrés que
70% de la masse d'eau s'évapore et que
du poisson crève dedans la réalité elle
est là dans dans le territoire moi je
viens du Perche en plus oui un paquet de
résidence secondaire
je pense que il y a eu des heures et des
heures de débat sur sur le sujet mais
vous nous referez connaître quelques
arguments supplémentaires il y a une
charte Johnson
qui nous reste s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît
oui mais il y avait eu un amendement de
conciliation qui avait été trouvé un
moment donné qui permettait de voilà
assez pertinent juste pour voir
peut-être sur les sujets
des poissons d'eau douce il y a 10 ans
les pollutions et puis les espèces
invasives si on est là aujourd'hui si
j'ai encore mobilisé nous sommes encore
mobilisés notre réseau c'est pour
justement maintenir la biodiversité dans
nos cours d'eau c'est-à-dire que les
espèces autochtones endémiques sont
encore présents dans nos cours d'eau
aussi bien à travers l'impact que pour
avoir les espèces invasives voient leur
développement mais surtout de faire que
leur cycle parce que le poisson il a un
cycle qui soit migrateur ou pas dans le
cours d'eau et il va de la montre va de
la valve vers la montée et vice-versa
donc il a besoin et c'est là où toute la
connexion de continuité écologique pour
son sens parce que un poisson suivant
son stade de développement n'a même pas
les mêmes capacités de développement etc
donc ça c'est le premier point je fais
très vite excusez-moi
petit électricité on l'a vu on l'a
rappelé aujourd'hui il faut pas
confondre quand on parle de d'ouvrage il
faut pas confondre le volume d'eau
mobilisable et le débit parce que quand
un moulin il est baissé et qui a plus
d'eau dans le bief c'est le début
j'irai du cours d'eau qui fait
potentiellement le productible sauf que
quand vous avez un filet d'eau comme ça
et que parce que je vous rappelle quand
même que la force hydraulique a été
abandonnée par les moulins entre 1820 et
1830 rapports historique à l'appui donc
c'est c'est pour montrer
recontextualiser ça à une époque on
n'était pas dans le baisse des cours du
dbdc cours d'eau dans un dérèglement de
climatique etc voilà alors maintenant on
va passer effectivement aux propositions
donc je vais je vais redonner la parole
un peu à 1000 puis moi j'en rajouterais
en deux minutes si vous voulez là
on vous a parlé du ministère de l'Eau
pour nous c'est vraiment une proposition
forte que l'on soutient le deuxième
point sur lequel on voulait vous
sensibiliser c'est cette notion de débit
qui à notre sens mérite une réflexion de
nature législative parce que le débit
réservé du 1/10 aujourd'hui et toutes
les exceptions que cet article 214 17
organise sont pour certaines en tout cas
plus adaptés à la réalité que nous
vivons c'est à dire un état de
sécheresse permanent pour faire court
voilà le sur l'aspect financier bon sur
l'aspect financier bon il va y avoir la
réforme des redevances mais mais quand
même la politique de l'eau a très
lourdement souffert de tout un tas de
mécanismes qui sont venus grever ses
finances publiques c'est finances les
finances des agences de l'eau je pense
notamment à ce qu'on appelait à une
époque le prélèvement exceptionnel mais
si on est fini mais maintenant on a le
plafond mordant bah ce sont autant de
dispositifs que nous on décrit parce
qu'ils viennent véritablement
Olivier les moyens voilà exactement de
neutraliser les moyens des agences de
l'eau
très bien sur le
très bien on est il y avait les deux
effectivement sur le volet juridique sur
le volet juridique
[Musique]
OK
on a eu un vrai un vrai sujet lors du
dernier conseil administration de
l'Office
de la police de l'eau et de
l'environnement du meilleur général
alors que c'est une police prioritaire
me semble-t-il excusez dans son contexte
voilà sur le volet juridique en deux
mots sur le volet juridique la politique
de ces 20 dernières années à consister à
faire en gros une espèce de GPEC une
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et
des compétences pour là aussi baisser
les moyens de certaines administrations
ça ça nous paraît totalement il y a 20
ans en appelé à la DDE on avait
forcément des gens en lien avec l'eau on
les a plus ce sont des experts qui sont
partis c'est quand même c'est quand même
un vraiment et sur le ce qu'on appelle
les iota la
nomenclature iota on est passé d'un
système où finalement il y avait
beaucoup de choses qui relevaient de
l'autorisation et qui dorénavant au
relève de ce qu'on appelle la
déclaration
moyen de du questionnaire tout ce que
vous avez pas pu dire vous auriez aimé
rajouter n'hésitez pas à nous faire une
contribution complète et merci
d'avoir été invités à échanger avec avec
vous-même et Messieurs sachez que
comment on ne se tarit pas à contrario
de l'eau dans nos cours d'eau
actuellement mais voilà et les moyens se
sont arrivés aussi que sont financiers
et de police et là il y a urgence il y a
un peu le feu la merde
jusqu'à juillet vous pouvez nous
apporter des éléments jusqu'à 8 juin